Bienvenidos a un episodio más de
historia en France 24 Mi nombre es
Álvaro Cordero el conflicto desatado en
Sudán entre el gobierno militar y el
grupo paramilitar de las fuerzas de
apoyo rápido también conocidas como Far
es solo el último episodio de violencia
en un país cuya normalidad durante las
últimas décadas ha sido la guerra y no
la paz un contexto que afecta a Sudán
desde su independencia y que ha llegado
la vida de millones de personas en los
últimos años por motivos políticos
étnicos o religiosos para entrar un poco
en contexto es necesario saber que Sudán
como nación soberana se formó en el año
1956 tras la independencia de Reino
Unido y Egipto pero que antes de su
independencia en el año 1955 Ya entró en
conflicto debido al inicio de la Primera
Guerra Civil sudanesa que se extendería
hasta el año 1972 y que solamente
tendría un período de paz hasta en 1983
iniciaría la Segunda Guerra Civil
sudanesa que finalizaría en 2005 en
estas guerras la población del Norte del
país musulmana y árabes enfrentó a la
población del Sur del país de mayoría
cristiana para entender esta situación
hay que tener en cuenta que tras su
independencia su dan se conformó como el
país más extenso de África y dentro de
esas fronteras que vemos había dos
realidades totalmente contrapuestas la
del Norte Por un lado como habíamos
comentado con mayoría árabe y musulmana
y que tenían el control en jartum la
capital y la del sur por otro lugar
donde había una serie de grupos étnicos
subsaharianos que tenían creencias
cristianas y animistas algo que les
enfrentó constantemente solamente la
Primera Guerra Civil sudanesa causó
medio millón de muertes en casi 17 años
esta constante inestabilidad hizo que
cualquier intento democrático fracasara
y favoreció a que en 1969 tras un golpe
de estado el coronel jafar al
numeritomar al poder Mary se convirtió
en el primer gran dictador de Sudán y
gobernó con mano de hierro durante casi
20 años su periodo trajo cierta
estabilidad al comienzo con la paz tras
la Primera Guerra Civil pero a partir de
1983 la Segunda Guerra Civil estalló y
los conflictos interétnicos se sumaron a
una gran hambruna en el occidente del
país que mató a cientos de miles y que
el gobierno militar ocultó
este contexto debilitó el poder de
numeric y favoreció que otro militar
llamado Omar albasier tomara el poder
por la fuerza en el año
1989 al basier centró sus esfuerzos en
combatir a las fuerzas opositoras del
sur e imponer la supremacía árabe e
islámica en todo el territorio algo que
multiplicó los conflictos en otras
regiones como Nilo azul o cordofán y que
hizo que la Segunda Guerra Civil
sudanesa fuera mucho peor que la primera
con casi 2 millones de muertes en 22
años además durante su periodo en el
poder Sudán fue incluida en la lista de
Estados terroristas por Estados Unidos
tras demostrarse vínculos entre la
dictadura y Osama Bin Laden algo que
supuso años de aislamiento internacional
a todo esto hay que sumar que
paralelamente a la guerra civil en 2003
estalló un conflicto interétnico en la
región occidental que dejó al menos
400.000 muertos según Naciones Unidas un
episodio donde se acusa a albasir de
realizar limpiezas étnicas a poblaciones
no árabes de la zona y por el cual la
Corte Penal Internacional emitió dos
órdenes de captura contra El dictador
por genocidio la credibilidad de albacir
mejoró a partir de 2005 con el fin de la
Segunda Guerra Civil y la garantía a la
zona sur del país de gozar de autonomía
una estabilidad que duró muy poco ya que
en 2011 se aprobó un referendo que dio
la independencia a Sudán del sur e hizo
que Sudán perdiera una cuarta parte de
su territorio y su mayor reserva de
hidrocarburos algo que trajo una
profunda crisis y que a largo plazo hizo
que en 2019 albasir fuera de puesto en
un golpe de estado y sustituido por un
gobierno de transición de dos años de
carácter Cívico militar
tras la caída de albasir el panorama de
Sudán era precisamente este durante esos
años se vivió un proceso democratizador
que hizo que se pusiera fin a varios
conflictos internos como el de darfur El
de cordofan del sur o el del Nilo azul
pero tanto los militares como los
paramilitares de esta nación mantuvieron
un poder bastante importante y también
mantuvieron altas las ansias de
enriquecerse por medio de la gran
cantidad de recursos naturales que allí
todavía en Sudán especialmente de las
minas de oro que como podemos ver en
este mapa son estos puntos amarillos que
vemos distribuidos dentro de la nación
africana así tras dos años de transición
en Sudán no se vivieron elecciones
democráticas y los civiles fueron
depuestos del poder después de un golpe
militar en octubre del año 2021
en ese golpe unieron fuerzas del fatah
alburham líder del ejército regu su
danés y Mohamed handan de galo apodado
gemetti El hombre fuerte de las FARC sin
embargo esa coalición tenía una Clara
fecha de caducidad debido a los
intereses personales de cada uno es aquí
cuando ante el temor por el gran poder
acaparado por las FARC Quienes cuentan
con el apoyo de otros grupos
paramilitares como Wagner el gobierno
militar sudanés decidió acabar con ellos
e iniciar el actual conflicto una
incipiente guerra civil en la que la
población volverá a ser la principal
víctima con esto concluimos Gracias por
compartir y comentar estas historias que
las encuentran en los programas de
France 24.com
[Música]